it's in seattle visiting my wife's uh
family uh and uh they are regular
listeners by the way oh no yeah shout
out to you no no they are shout out to
the powells in uh in seattle they are
lovely people they put on a great
thanksgiving uh feast for us all and i
had a really good time and i love being
in seattle yeah because
my genetic structure
insists that i'd be in a cold wet
climate yeah and um my body is screaming
at me all the time i'm in los angeles
get away get away get away and then when
i'm up in uh what basically is northern
ireland
aka seattle
uh i'm very zen i really love it there
people are very nice isn't there this is
going to be a downer isn't there just a
high suicide rate because of the weather
in seattle only when i'm in town
suicide rates peak when i show up people
are so upset you're there
well no i didn't say there was any
linkage they just said that there's a
huge spike when i show up in town oh
that's why during thanksgiving while you
were gone i just wanted to live
also rates plummet in la la when i leave
yeah um but i had an interesting moment
where i was in the airport and uh you
know you go through you you have your
bags and you you check them in my wife
and i had kids had bags that we had to
check in because we brought different
stuff we had brought bigger bags we
couldn't we couldn't bring them on the
airplane so we uh we're checking the
bags in and the guy said hey uh i just
want to thank you uh he's the guy that
was checking our bags and he said well
thank you
you've been uh you've been speaking
truth to power for a long time and you
brought down a lot of really bad dudes
huh you know with your truth telling on
the air and i thought
he has the wrong guy i don't know
i don't know i have never i've never
spoken truth to power
i've been foolish and silly around power
but it was just really he and he really
i couldn't say anything i didn't want to
say sir i think you have the wrong
person because he was so happy to meet
me and he just said you've taken a lot
you've taken down a lot of strong
a lot of like bad men
um yeah and he went on and on about uh
how i'm like a crime fighter with my
career on television
and i didn't say anything and then
walked away and felt
yeah he basically just thanked captain
crunch for all the good he's done
i don't even know who he would have
confused me maybe he's talking about
stephanie i don't know who he thought i
was but
somewhere in seattle there's a guy who
really idolizes me
because i brought down the mob